In the previous videos, you could see how we did during the winter break,
and what's coming for this third season at Project Kamp.
Now, we're really starting to think!
In this episode, we are going to renovate,
and customize a strong old car we bought.
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
We need a car for our daily work, here at the Kamp.
So, we bought a second hand pickup from the 90s...
Big, strong, and durable.
The engine is in good condition,
but the car needs some fixes, and maintenance...
It took a while to find it, because this kind of car
is very popular, in the Portuguese countryside...
We want to give some love to this old beast,
and also, we want to have a nice customized look.
So, we will have a dashboard made out of recycled wood and fabric.
So, hello!
Here we have our new old car!
We used to have another old car too,
but we didn't stop to repair the whole time...
So, we want an old car that we are able
to repair ourselves, that is reliable...
This is a big upgrade for us!
We have a pickup now, where we can put a lot of materials inside...
We can carry big pieces...
We can carry our waste...
We can carry way more people too!
But, as you can see, the car is not in the best condition...
There's some rust problems...
The box is rusting here, and creates puddles inside...
The wood is not that bad, but just looks a bit old.
Some parts of this box, as you can see,
are not in the best condition...
There's a broken part here too...
Little things...
Well, not the perfect state...
A sketchy repair from the old owner.
All this putty on top of the rust...
Disgusting...
We also need to improve the safety of it, a bit...
As you can see...
Almost ready...
And, under the hood, we also want to make some little things.
We actually got this car, because it looks bad on the outside,
but its 'heart' is in very good condition.
Still, we want to do the basic maintenance of it...
Basic things, to make it last longer.
We will try to reuse as much parts as we can, from this car.
Repair as much as we can...
We will go to the scrapyard to find the same car,
and try to get all pieces for it.
Maybe, we'd find some bigger things...
We hope not.
We also have Hans here to help us with this!
- Hello!
So, this is Hans!
He is a Dutch guy, who lives close by.
Although, he is not part of the team,
he is a very good friend of the project!
He has such a passion for old cars,
that he gets really fast into work!
So, the first thing to do:
we will start with the basic maintenance of the car.
Change filters, change oils, etcetera...
To have it ready to start.
- We changed the oil filter!
Look at this!
We think that there was a super strong mechanic,
before working in this car...
Because, it's so strongly connected, we can't get it from its connector...
So, we need to put a hole inside, and turn it with the bar.
- Easy job!
Now, a new filter...
New oil, and I'm ready!
The filters and oil is ready, so let's see if the car starts again
I always had my own Land Rovers in a building,
and I bought cheap ones.
I took them apart and restored them all...
- Ah, cool!
Do you have a Land Rover now?
- No...
No?
I left them in Holland.
Yeah, the first year I thought it was pity,
because there's lots of roads here.
It's good for a Land Rover, but now, I'm glad it's over.
- Yeah?
Yeah...
Always in your back, always your hands broken...
And now, it's good as a hobby,
but you should sometimes leave your hobbies alone...
We are gonna take apart the box of the pickup now.
To see what is the state...
And, we will fix all that we can.
There's the angle of the box.
It's slightly up, which means that these two lines are not parallel...
It makes that, when the bumpy roads come...
Touches the car too...
Another problem that it generates,
is like it creates puddles in the box.
When it rains, because it's like this.
So, we will try to make it straight, to make the water go out,
and prevent these areas from touching
To be more safe.
Take care of your hands, yeah?
Wow, 'mooi'!*
* meaning 'nice' in Dutch
It's nice like this!
And the lights are not working, in your reverse light!
Blinkers?
This one is good!
Yeah, they work!
The light, its the glass that is not good...
They made this on this wood...
And, so, we cannot take them out...
You can see that they're all rusted...
I don't think it will turn, so,
what we have to do is make new holes there...
And, make the whole thing new.
I've never repaired a car with a saw!
Looks like new...
Cut it here, Cut it here, and try to cut it here.
So, we're gonna weld a big disk, in order to make it sturdy.
Here we have the back bumper.
And, it just cracked here, so there is a hole...
So, we're going to weld it together, so it's strong again.
Okay, so far, we fixed the structure of the car,
and the bottom of the box.
But, we see that the beams underneath are rotten,
and we need to remake them...
So, Jaime will use one of them as a template.
And, with leftover wood, that we keep in the bottom
of the office, we will make new ones.
We will protect them with the used car oil,
that we took from the motor.
After looking at it on the internet,
I found a guy that might have some spare parts for our car.
So, we're gonna meet him now,
and see what he has there...
So, we already have the pieces in the Kamp!
Ready to be installed, and replace the pieces,
that are broken from our car...
Someone took care of his car so much!
Again, we are reusing the oil we replaced from the pickup
Hans says it's not really necessary...
- I don't need to do this...
I only do this, because it looks nice.
But, we feel it will protect our leaf springs better, in the long run.
We will continue now, fixing many small details, around the car...
With some ingenuity, and the part we got from the scrapyard.
- Yeah, like new!
Time to change this annoying mirror...
Yeah...
Good now!
Goodmorning Hans!
Very good.
- Expensive, or no?
Five euros.
It changes the look...
It does, it really does change the look, yeah...
This is not safe.
So, here we lost all the information about the fuses...
But, we luckily found a new piece!
With the right information on it...
So, we can replace the fuses and replace the lid.
Done!
So, we have replaced the old frame for new fresh beams!
We have treated the wood with the oil, that was in the car.
Now, we already put the box in place.
We will treat the wood and the metal,
to give a long life to this old box...
Now, we're trying to go and see,
if we can find some tools inside!
Because, we need to do things here on the car,
with the tools of the car...
But, that's a very big problem,
because the tools are behind the seat...
And the seat can't open without a rope...
And, the rope has disappeared, so,
that will be a very interesting problem...
- Exactly...
Look at this!
- Jesus!
Glass!
And, nails...
See if you can find-
yeah I found the rope
It's antique!
Antique nails...
Almost as old as the car...
30 years of--
( negligence )
I had to take everything out!
Just to find this little piece of...
I don't know what it is...
Rope, or plastic?
And, now we can reach what we were looking for...
The wrench here, and the jack.
Do you think your father will be watching the video?
- if he is going to watch it?
- I think so, yeah!
He would have a lot of opinions!
Yeah!
Very heavy!
Does it open?
Yes of course
That's no problem.
If you're strong...
Funny, funny, funny!
We have the spare tire here, and we need
to attach it to the bottom of the car.
just put this in...
start wrenching!
I hope I didn't do anything
I already oiled it.
You see how smooth it is.
And, this will stay in...
The pipe is leaking every time you put diesel oil in it...
The idea of this thing is to make a new connection,
between these two.
And, we've cut this in half, took this off,
make these two together, and mount it under the car.
So, now it's like the old one,
but only made of two pieces of...
What's it called in English?
- Pipe?
Pipe!
Two thin pieces of pipe...
I'm satisfied with all the things we've done!
Because, now, everything is repaired what was broken...
- Yeah!
And, that's good!
- Yeah...
We had some little issues with this dashboard,
that was a bit like broken, and all the plastic was old...
So, now, we're gonna try to make something nice out of it!
And, get a nice finishing..
Something that is nice to drive behind...
You can see the good views,
plus the good looking, of the inside of the car, after this...
Up and down,
left and right!
Woah!
Yeaaah....
Kevin!
- Yeah?
They found this!
What do you think?
Could you use them?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah!
They are so broken...
They have some holes...
- Yeah, their back is useful...
The back is useful, eh?
The front?
- I don't want to look at you from the front...
No?
- Way too exposed!
Okay, but you can use it?
- Yeah!
Nice!
Ok!
Okay, now that the work is done,
let's have a drive-around to see how it feels.
After the first test of the car,
everything is starting good!
Everything works!
It seems that we put everything in place!
It sounds better!
It drives better!
But now, we want to test it for real, on a dirt road.
Thank you guys!
We came to the local garage.
And, we will replace our old tires,
for something more suitable for our land...
With the old tires, we will bring it back to the Kamp,
to see what we can do with them.
We will give it another try now.
Let's see how it goes!
It works!
So, it's been a hard work to renovate this car, but also fun!
We love how it drives, and how it looks!
We will check how it behaves during the season...
But, at the moment, we are excited to have it ready!
It's always difficult to choose between older,
and less efficient stuff...
Or, newer and more efficient.
This time, we decide to give a new life to this old guy,
since it's a better fit to our current situation.
Curious to hear how you make these choices.
For now, we will make the most out of it...
And, hope it lasts many more years!
It works perfect!
It's quite good!
Everything works nice...
No problems, and smooth...
What else can you ask for?
In the next update, we will upgrade Basekamp,
with a new container for storage.
We will also build a big metal roof on top!
If you want to see it now, you can support us on Patreon.
And, you will have access to all our videos, one week ahead!
If not, you can subscribe, and drop a comment,
to help us with the algorithm.
Thanks for watching, and see you in the next episode!